cupcake
think very carefully about what you're
about to do
i was here first because it's my cupcake
i bought it it's my cupcake
you guys haven't done it that's my
cupcake
i have the turkey i'm the cutest
[Music]
grandma
okay guys okay okay wait wait wait wait
i know how we're going to settle this
nerf war
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
there we go 400 pounds of legos
okay
[Music]
rebecca is this your castle well i
picked my location very poorly
don't worry it's
oh yeah you're a host we're we're right
there
[Music]
all right let's load up and get ready
[Music]
you ready to fight for the cupcake yeah
go and get it
[Music]
oh oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ready for the secret weapons
[Music]
for the cupcakes
oh
[Music]
nathan curse your sudden but inevitable
betrayal
oh
do i've got marks on my back
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is pointless hold on hold on hold
on everybody come on come on okay
ow hey hey okay okay hey
why don't we just be adults here
and we can just split the cupcake
okay we're gonna split the cupcake okay
let's just go upstairs and split the
cupcake
oh jacob did you eat the cupcake
ah
if you liked this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
oh my goodness there are darts
everywhere
who's gonna clean all this up